i did it mainly to create um highlight
and make people more aware and celebrate
our areas the communities where we were
walking are a protected area um i had a
fantastic team of local men amerindians
with us and the other reason i really
wanted to do this was to encourage and
inspire more people to get outside into
our wildernesses
okay so talk to me about what the most
challenging part was
you know i we had we faced daily
challenges and every day we woke up and
it was so unknown what we were going to
face but i think some of the biggest
challenges were the maps were 50 years
old so that was very very challenging
every day and the the forest was so
dense that sometimes we were moving
meters at a time and at times you know
we we thought we weren't even going to
be home for christmas and we had skin
infections we were always running away
from wasps and um i think there was a
sense of are we have we got ourselves in
too deep here because it really i'm
surprised i'm the most surprised of
everyone that we managed to pull this
off let alone
do it successfully and safely
what was the biggest mental challenge
for you
um mentally i think
when we were sort of the first few weeks
when it was so hard
um we had a lot of encounters with
snakes and it felt a huge responsibility
for me maybe i've put this team and
myself into this too dangerous scenario
because rescue was so so far away even
though we had a fantastic operation
manager anders anderson it would have
taken days to get get us to safety so
just that feeling of feeling so
vulnerable and so unsafe was a huge huge
mental strain
i hear that you uh didn't see daylight
for 17 days at a time what was that
about
yeah so because um we were traversing
just under the forest and we we hit two
main rivers during the whole route but
under the canopy it's so so dark and the
trees are so high and so dense the sun
just is not getting through so it's
getting it's getting dark completely by
sort of 3 4 p.m
and you just don't get that sunlight on
you and it does get quite um quite
intense not having that
yeah i'm sure i'm sure um where did you
sleep were you not worried about spiders
and things
spiders i mean they have the goliath
giant the giant bird eating spider but
to be honest they were the least of our
worries the snakes and the big cats and
the peccary which are wild poor they
travel in up to 500 um then you have to
get get away from the climbing trees um
but that's exactly why we we camp in
hammocks so if it's in a particular
dangerous place you actually raise the
hammocks even higher than you would
normally be so that things can pass
under you um but yeah the snakes they
have been known to go underneath your
hammock and get your warmth and strike
when you least expect it uh so even
though you're in your hammock you're not
not entirely safe
did you have any bites
oh gosh if we had had a bite then um
that would have been game over we had
some very very close encounters where um
vivian one of his team members almost
fell onto a snake twice
uh but so by some luck luck played a
huge part of this um
we managed to avoid it and well oh it
would have been yeah it would be very
bad if that happened you're talking
about the wasps and things though did
they manage to um track you down or were
you always just ahead of those as well
oh no there was got goddess every time
they're i've been stung by so many wasps
i hope i'm immune now from british west
and when i say wasps they have
everything from ones that chase you for
a mile and you just have to run as fast
as you can and they come in this warm
you or you have one where i got a very
unattractive sting on the eye which
swells falls up and this wasp is about
that big and we actually saw it um and
one time dragging a tarantula so it's
it's a mighty mighty wasp these things
wow
and what about the um animals you're
talking about jaguar and wild boars did
you see many of those
yeah we did we saw jaguars and we saw
pumas peccary the world war we were we
were running away constantly um they
were everywhere they don't have a
population problem there for sure um but
i was always looking out for trees that
i could climb to get away from them um
they are very scary things actually you
hear them um grinding their teeth when
they're coming and then you have to be
prepared to go
okay what's next
what's next i've got so much so much
planned um i've just you know i've only
scratched the surface of how great
there's all this world and the
adventures to come so yeah i'm i'm
plotting some things that's for sure oh
you're not going to tell us
i know no definitely not i've got a got
lots to be lots to be um plans
okay do you promise that you'll come
back and talk to us again when you can
i'd love to thank you